Joe Biden is alive barely CNN reveals
its agenda and Bernie Sanders scraps
with Elizabeth Warren plus happy
birthday to me I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show the Ben Shapiro
show is sponsored by expressvpn protect
your online privacy today at Express VPN
comm slash Ben well it is indeed my
birthday and there's no better way to
spend a birthday Eve than watching all
people scream at each other really makes
you feel that impending sense of doom
that accompanies companies every
birthday sort of naturally my birthday
I'm 36 today by the way so
congratulations to me I also get to vote
twice now I believe under the
Constitution which was always the case
in Chicago but under the Federal
Constitution since I'm twice the legal
voting age I get to vote twice I think
that's the way this works I get to fake
play my favorite game of the year on my
birthday it's called how many members of
the political left on Twitter will text
me or email me happy birthday but not
actually say happy birthday openly on
Twitter for fear of acknowledging that I
am a human and then being blasted by the
black the backlash and getting cancelled
so looking forward to playing that game
but last night to the news last night
was the Rock'em Sock'em robots debate we
were all waiting for what it really came
down to is that everybody was very mean
to Bernie and yet you had to feel a
little bit bad for the guy after all
after years of being a committed
communist somebody who says that we
should all live together the heart of
man is inherently good he learned last
night that for every Trotsky there is a
Stalin he learned last night that all of
your former allies all of your friends
will stab you in the back and put an ice
pick through your political eye as soon
as they see the opportunity to
consolidate power he learned that from
no less than our Native American
princess Elizabeth Warren so after the
debate after debate this is pretty
fantastic it had a bit of a scratch for
him as you'll see and after the debate
Elizabeth Warren walks over to Bernie
Sanders and Bernie puts out his hand to
shake her hand and she refuses to shake
his hand and she literally just does not
shake his hand and then they start
getting into it and Tom Styer is over
there he goes to shake Bernie Sanders
head Tom Styer now we know that Tom
Styer is gonna be sort of like Orson
Welles at the end of Citizen Kane that
on his deathbed he's going to be holding
a snow globe filled with a model of the
debate and we're all going to
what exactly Bernie said to Warren and
what Warren said to Bernie and steyr is
gonna die without telling us hopefully
when he hits 120 but man that is some
nasty stuff Warren is a nasty human
being and there is a reason I have
nothing but sympathy honestly for all
the Sanders supporters out there who
were hashtagging never worn after this
I'm with you man
she is a jerk she's a jerk because if
she actually felt like Bernie Sanders
was a sexist all the way along why not
just say that after December 2018 when
he had the meeting with him instead of
trying to hug him and be best friends
with him and then two weeks before the
Iowa caucuses that's when you dropped
this supposed bombshell that he said a
woman can't be President first of all
the story itself does not hold together
it doesn't make any sense
you know like look at the conversation
went something like this Elizabeth
Warren said I really want to run for
president because I think that a woman
can defeat Donald Trump and Princeton I
don't think it provides any special
advantage and then she was like wow that
means that he says a woman can't be
President that means a woman can be
president and she's gonna drop that two
weeks before through her surrogates and
then deny that she dropped it and then
suggest that she doesn't want to talk
about it and then after the debate is
over she's gonna walk up to Bernie
Sanders and refuse to shake his hand
she's a jerk and she's a she's a bad
she's a bad person she's a nasty person
and the fact that all the Bernie bros
are beginning to notice that Elizabeth
Warren is pretty nasty now this is this
is well merited Bernie Sanders didn't
get great treatment from the DNC last
time around it appears he is not gonna
get great treatment from the DNC this
time around he's certainly not getting
great treatment from the media the story
of last night is that Joe Biden
continues to sit over there being a dead
person hey Joe Biden it does show the
great wondrous tolerance and diversity
of the United States that anyone can be
elected president even a person who's
been dead for the last six years that's
really exciting stuff here in the United
States of America we've had a black
president we've had many white
presidents and now we'll have a dead
president which is actually really I
think again a sign of America's
commitment to openness but Joe Biden
basically just sat there and and babbled
to himself for two hours meanwhile
Bernie and Elizabeth Warren went after
each other and CNN jumped in CNN went
after Bernie harder than any of the
other candidates now a lot of the Bernie
bros today are very upset with CNN
welcome to our world gang welcome to the
world the right wing where CNN has
consistently pushed a particular
narrative they are not objective in any
way shape or form
they never really
try to be objective in any way shape or
form but they proclaim that they are
objective if you're a burning person
today you are fighting mad and this
gonna backlash on Warren I don't think
that this is actually gonna pay off for
more and the media today Oh Warren had a
good night way I don't think that's
right I think that the backlash from
Warren is gonna be pretty strong because
she did not appear to be a nice person
she appeared to be a very very mean
person in fact she appeared to be
somebody who is attacking Bernie Sanders
unfairly cutting the legs out from under
him is basically a cut block in the NFL
just went right for the knees and she
did so late away from the actual play
and then it wasn't flagged in fact the
flag was thrown on the guy who got cut
blocked it is pretty incredible so we're
gonna get to all of the details from
this insanely boring debate except for
some of the fisticuffs between Sanders
and Morin well get to the fact that
these people are utterly unqualified to
be President of the United States not
because of their service but because
their views are just nutty they're just
nutty and confused and ridiculous and
the Democratic Party is looking for more
confused ridiculous nutty views
apparently look at all that in just one
second we'll go through this this debate
detail by detail but first are you
feeling fatigued and tired today well if
you watch that debate you certainly are
do you feel a little bit like Bernie
Sanders you know banged up like you're
on the verge of a heart attack or
something well you know what you could
probably use liquid IV look what I the
energy multiplier gives you sustained
energy throughout the day you can fight
fatigue without the crash it's an all
natural alternative to processed energy
drinks and can even help you kick the
coffee habit if that's something that
you're trying to do say get those those
headaches from not having your coffee in
the morning liquid IV can help you out
liquid IVs cellular transport technology
delivers an optional ratio of nutrients
for more efficient uptake they've got
enhanced rapid absorption into the
bloodstream that gives you a lasting
energy boost quickly it powers your
mornings it feels long days at work
provides a boost for those tough
workouts got clean ingredients non-gmo
vegan free of gluten dairy and soy folks
who work are trying it it's keeping
their energy up keeping their
productivity up that's what we care
about here at the daily wire get 25% off
when you go to liquid IV calm and use
code been at checkout that is 25% off
anything you order on liquid IVs website
just go to liquid IV calm and for promo
code been to save 25% and get better
hydration and energy that is liquid IV
calm promo code been don't wait start
fueling your adventures and your life
today liquid IV calm and use that promo
code baton for 25
percent off alrighty so last night's
debate began with some talk about
foreign policy and you can hear CNN
going after burning from the very
beginning from the very beginning now
listen I think that the questions asked
to Bernie Sanders are perfectly fair
except for one one question was
certainly unfair but most of the
questions were pretty fair I just think
that it's weird that nobody had asked
Bernie Sanders a tough question for 45
50 years of his career and then last
night CNN chooses to wake up just in
time to try and push more before the
Iowa caucuses if you watch Huffington
Post if you watch CNN if you watch MSNBC
it is perfectly obvious that the person
they dread the most in the Democratic
Party is Bernie Sanders they do not want
Bernie Sanders to be the nominee now
some of them don't like Joe Biden very
much but there is a general consensus
that Elizabeth Warren is wonderful and
this has not faded
even though Elizabeth Warren has faded
and despite the fact that Warren has
dropped in the pack
the media continued to try to prop her
up because the media still prefer the
media she makes them feel good about
themselves you have to understand
members of the media are upper crust
coastal elites who like to believe that
they are intellectuals and Elizabeth
Warren is like straight at it's also the
reason a lot of them like people who to
judge it's it's that sort of background
that makes them feel special it makes
them feel good about themselves
so last night CNN went hard Efrain Wolf
Blitzer start off yes I'm a fair
question about his foreign policy but he
doesn't ask anybody else this foreign
policy question in this way here is Wolf
Blitzer going after Bernie Sanders
senator Sanders in the wake of the Iran
crisis arange Ayatollah Khamenei Yee has
again called for all US troops to be
pulled out of the Middle East something
you've called for as well yet when
American troops last left Iraq Isis
emerged and spread terror across the
Middle East and indeed around the world
how would you prevent that from
happening again
let me tell you but before I tell you
that we tell you something else okay and
then he didn't really tell anybody
anything else but the bottom line is
that that question is brutal right how
would you prevent it don't you basically
have Isis's agenda right don't you have
Ron's agenda now again I think that's a
fair question I just think it's weird
that CNN decides to pull that club out
of its pocket in the last debate before
Iowa and now when it comes to the actual
foreign policy debate in the Democratic
Party
it's basically between people who are
90% wrong and people
100% wrong Joe Biden is in the 90% wrong
category he still has some tenuous grasp
of reality through the foggy haze of his
increasing dementia Joe Biden still
seems to have some sort of grasp of the
fact that the United States is supposed
to play a role in the world and you know
look the fact is that he did sit in that
VP seat for years and once you're in the
White House we've had three straight
presidents four really if you include
Clinton I think this is right four
straight presidents who basically said
the United States should disengage from
the world and then when they are sitting
in the big seat they've not disengage
from the world in any real way Joe Biden
has spent some time in the White House
he understands you can't disengage from
the world but the problem for Joe Biden
is that Joe Biden has to apologize for
his own record on his foreign policy
because the Democratic Party is filled
with people who believe in the Bernie
Sanders isolationist America is bad
America is terrible America victimizes
people on the world stage that so Biden
said for example yeah he apologized said
in 2002 when Congress was debating
whether or not we got into a war in ROK
invade Iraq I got up on the floor I said
it would be a disaster it would lead to
unprecedented levels of chaos in the
region I not and then he said that um
sorry he said that by that that's
actually quote from Sanders Biden
actually suggested that he had
apologized for his role in the Iraq war
that he should not have voted in favor
of the Iraq war and then Sanders because
he represents again that isolationist
wing of the Democratic Party Sanders and
then clocks him across the head in 2002
when the Congress was debating whether
or not we go into a war in Iraq
invade Iraq I got up on the floor of the
house and I said that would be a
disaster it would lead to unprecedented
levels of chaos in the region and I'd
not only voted against the war I helped
lead the effort against that wall it is
pretty incredible that for the
Democratic Party your chief foreign
policy win is not voting in favor of a
war that had broad bipartisan support
because it is always easy to say in the
aftermath of a war that it was really
that that it was really bad and when's
the last time somebody's like yeah I
backed the war and it was great well
that hasn't happened really since World
War two so the easy position in foreign
policy is always the no position that's
always the easy position the yes
position is always the hard position
when it comes to when it comes to war
nobody wants to make war nobody there's
not a bunch of people in the United
States were like yeah war all the time
and I'm frankly getting very sick of the
straw man that is set up by folks on the
isolationist right as well as on the
left that if people believe the United
States should take an active role in the
world that this is because they are pro
war it's just absolute nonsense from
beginning to end this contrasts pretty
strongly with Joe Biden this clip for
talking about what actually has to
happen in terms of foreign policy which
is yes we are not going to stop being
engaged in the Middle East
I would leave troops in the Middle East
in terms of patrolling the Gulf where we
have to where we are now small numbers
of troops and I think it's a mistake to
pull out the straw the small number of
troops that are there now to deal with
Isis so there is Joe Biden being
realistic about war but you're not
allowed to be realistic about war
instead you're supposed to be
unrealistic and this is what Elizabeth
Warren most calculated candidate in the
field knows she says no no no we're
gonna withdraw forthwith incredibly fast
because again this is the way that you
win a Democratic primary I think we need
to get our combat troops out you know we
have to stop this mindset that we can do
everything with combat troops our
military is the finest military on earth
and they will take any sacrifice we
asked them to take but we should stop
asking our military to solve problems
that cannot be solved militarily so the
Sanders Warren wing on foreign policy is
utterly out of touch with reality Joe
Biden is sort of out of touch with
reality so Joe Biden wants to have it
both ways on the one hand he wants to
suggest that he is hawkish enough to
keep America safe on the other hand he
wants to suggest that he is actually not
all that hawkish at all and so he ends
up rewriting his own record in bizarre
ways Oh Joe Biden he was actually called
on this by CNN as he should have been he
talked about how when he first ran for
Congress he was very focused on the
informed consent of the American people
to go to war here's Joe Biden saying a
thing that is about to come back to bite
him in the debate I ran the first time
as a 29 year old kid against the war in
Vietnam on the grounds that only its way
to can take a nation wars with the
informed consent of the American people
the informed consent of the American
people yeah Libya Libya drone war like a
few things that your
ministration did also I do love the fact
that the Democrats who have declared
they want to be friendly diplomacy
diplomacy friendly as soon as Donald
Trump basically did what Barack Obama
pledged to do and met with kim
jeong-hoon
now joe biden's like i would never meet
kim jeong-hoon without preconditions
this is pretty funny no not now
i wouldn't meet without any
preconditions look well we gave him
everything he's looking for legitimacy
the president showed up met with him
gave him legitimacy weakened the
sanctions we have against them said on
stage that he would meet with kim
jeong-hoon with iran without any
preconditions whatsoever right that's
the thing he actually said now joe biden
is taking the reverse position why
because Donald Trump actually ended up
taking the Obama position in a second we
will get to the Democrats on trade but
then we get to the actual the actual
center of the democratic debate
Joe Biden gets to stand to the side well
Elizabeth Warren and Bernie Sanders go
at it like the Bolsheviks in the
Mensheviks circa 1918 it's really
exciting stuff we'll get to that in just
one second first let's talk about your
safety and security so let me just say
my wife and I are paranoid about safety
this has been exacerbated by the fact
that we were XIV an enormous number of
deaths unfortunately that's just the
life but the good news is we feel
protected why because we use ring rings
mission is to make neighborhoods safer
they're smart video doorbells and
cameras protect millions of people
everywhere this is actually particularly
important in Los Angeles there's been a
spate of break-ins in the general area
where I live pretty important to know
that your home is safe also there are a
lot of folks who will ring the doorbell
make sure that you're not home and then
break-in well if you got ring they ring
the doorbell you can pick it up from
your phone they have no idea what their
home or not ring helps you stay
connected to your home anywhere in the
world so if there's a package delivery
or a surprise visitor you get an alert
you're able to see here and speak to
them all from your phone listen I have
real security risks that's why I use
ring if you don't have nearly as high
security risks I mean that's a good
reason to use ring if you can keep me
safe we can certainly keep you safe and
that one time when somebody breaks in
your house you're gonna wish that you'd
installed ring as a subscriber you have
a special offer on the ring welcome kit
available right now at ring.com slash
been the kit includes a video doorbell
and a chime Pro which is just what you
need to start building a ring of
security around your home today go to
ring.com slash men again that is
ring.com slash bam ok then joe biden and
bernie sanders go
added on trade so Bernie Sanders his
view of trade is even more isolationist
than Trump he's actually Pro tariffs he
believes in an almost bizarre
socialistic autarky he believes that we
should produce all product in the United
States and basically have zero trade
with foreign countries which is idiocy
of the highest order
but again in the Democratic primary
there is an advantage to purity is one
thing that you learn about the primaries
there is there's an advantage to being
pure of hearts even if stupid of head
that is Bernie Sanders in a nutshell so
Bernie Sanders and and Joe Biden go
ahead a Biden says listen there's no
trade agreement that Sandra's Ravello
for because he's been useless for thirty
years I don't know that there's any
trade agreement that the senator would
ever think made any sense but the
problem is that ninety-five percent of
the customers are out there so we better
figure out how we begin to write the
rules of the road not China okay and
then Bernie puts up his finger cuz he
wants to talk and he says listen I just
don't like braid trade is bad because
trade does not and it does not adhere to
my sense of what is fair and what is
right
namely that everybody should have 1
million dollars Joe and I have a
fundamental disagreement here okay I
have a notice and that is NAFTA PNTR
with China other trade agreements were
written for one reason alone and that is
to increase the profits of large
multinational corporations and the end
result of those two just PNTR with China
Joe and NAFTA cost us some four million
jobs as part of the race for the bottle
okay well it didn't actually cost
america four million jobs it did shift
manufacturing overseas because it turns
and manufactured things more cheaply
overseas it was mostly technology
actually that did all of that most of
the manufacturing jobs lost in the
united states we're not lost to china or
mexico they were lost to technological
advancement but job growth in the united
states has never ceased i mean there are
more people employed today than were at
the beginning of nafta manufacturing
growth actually maintained its rates in
the first few years of nafta it was only
that it started to drop off in the
aftermath specifically of technological
advances in the late 90s but again
they're significant divides between joe
biden who again has that tenuous grasp
of reality and bernie sanders who has no
grasp of reality and still lives in
cloud cuckoo-land wear Stalin's
five-year plans were actually excellent
okay but now we get to the heart of the
matter this is all kind of normal
Democrats abate stuff Joe Biden versus
Bernie Sanders Sanders being radical but
pure of heart and Joe Biden being a
little less pure of heart but also a
little bit less radical then we get to
the spicy stuff and this is CNN deciding
on the basis of noting that Bernie
Sanders is a liar like just deciding
that Bernie Sanders is a liar and
Elizabeth Warren shining it chiming and
it's unbelievable
this is truly this is astonishing stuff
so Abbey Philip is the name of this
reporter s at CNN and she jumps on
Sanders and we're gonna play the whole
exchange we'll pause it all the way
through and you will see how a and you
will see I mean this is just it's an
amazing exchange here we go let's not
turn to an issue that's come up in the
last 48 hours senator Sanders see none
reported yesterday that and senator
Sanders senator Warren confirmed in a
statement that in 2018 you told her that
you did not believe that a woman could
win the election why did you say that
well as a matter of fact I didn't say oh
and I don't want to waste a whole lot of
time on this because this is what Donald
Trump and maybe some of the media want
anybody knows me knows that it's
incomprehensible that I would think that
a woman could not be President of the
United States go to youtube today
there's some video of that of me thirty
years ago talking about how a woman
could become president of the United
States in 2015 I deferred in fact the
Senate Awards was a movement to draft
Senator Warren to run for president and
you know what I said stayed back senator
Warren decided not to run and I they I
did run afterwards Hillary Clinton won
the popular vote by three million votes
how could anybody in a million years not
believe that a woman could become
president of the United States and let
me be very clear if any of the women on
this stage or any of the men on this
stage win the nomination I hope that's
not the case I hope it's me but if they
do I will do everything in my power to
make sure that they are elected
in order to defeat the most dangerous
president in the history of our country
so senator Sanders you're saying that
you never told senator Warren that a
woman could not win the election that is
correct senator Warren what did you
think when senators Andrew Sanders told
you a woman could not win the election I
disagreed Bernie is my friend and I am
not here to try to fight with Bernie but
look this question about whether or not
a woman can be president has been raised
in it's time for us to attack it head-on
and I think the best way to talk about
who can win is by looking at people's
winning record
so can a woman beat Donald Trump look at
the men on this stage collectively they
have lost 10 elections the only people
on this stage who have won every single
election that they've been in are the
women person on this stage who has
beaten an incumbent Republican any time
in the past 30 years is me okay that is
an unbelievably garbage exchange by CNN
unbelievable I mean it's a full analysis
of just how bad that exchange is I mean
truly awful exposed to CNN and it's full
glory exposes Elizabeth Warren for the
cynical political that she is honestly I
feel bad for burning like you have made
me feel bad for Bernie Sanders how I
spent all of yesterday's show crapping
in Bernie Sanders's cornflakes okay
Bernie Sanders is a communist and now I
feel bad for him because of you people
because of you CNN because of you
Elizabeth Warren he's just awful
caring against a full analysis of this
fun real exchange in just one second Joe
Biden by the way just sitting off there
going well I don't know where I am but
this is pretty fantastic get to that in
just one second first let us talk about
life insurance so it is my birthday that
means I'm thinking about death I mean
that's what you do on your birthday as
you get older you think that's one more
year off the calendar so one year closer
to the grave maybe if you're thinking
about that because I just mentioned it
you should go get life insurance I mean
do a practical thing turn your sadness
into joy by getting some life insurance
and ensuring that at least your family's
taken care of in case god forbid
something she
happen to you the people you go to you
know what I'm gonna say policy genius
policy genius calm makes finding the
right insurance a breeze in minutes you
can compare quotes from the top insurers
and find your best price you could say
1500 bucks or more a year by using
policy genius to compare life insurance
policies once you apply the policy
genius team will handle all the
paperwork and the red tape and policy
genius doesn't just make life insurance
easy they can also help you find the
right home and auto insurance disability
insurance getting life insurance if you
got a family particularly moral
obligation so why wait around why be
depressed about your own demise instead
just ensure against it listen none of us
can avoid death but certainly your
family can avoid some of the financial
fallout go check them out at policy
genius Calm everybody gets the future
wrong but we know what's coming don't
get your insurance wrong policy
genius.com go check it out right now
policy genius.com okay so the
ridiculousness of this exchange is just
astonishing so Phillip leads off by
saying CNN reported yesterday well if
CNN reported it as we all know that must
mean that the underlying facts are true
it can't just be that somebody from the
warren campaign decided to leave a
flaming bag of dog poop on Bernie
Sanders's
Bernie Sanders his doorstep and use CNN
as the delivery service it can't just be
that notes that CNN reported it so
Sanders is response is a fine response
you can see that Sanders is just
confused that any of this is how mean
he's confused most of the time he's
particularly confused that any of this
is happening and honestly I understand
the charm of Bernie Sanders he's like a
crazy old coot he's a crazy old coot who
seems like he's honest and he's honestly
wrong he's honestly dumb but he's honest
right and then you get CNN responding in
the confirming that Bernie Sanders says
that this never took place and they've
got CNN is broadcasting this so they've
got this on split screen with with
Elizabeth Warren looking very
disapproving looking very upset looking
like how could anyone believe how women
believe all women hashtag me Jo and then
Abbey Philip follows up Bernie Sanders's
responds by simply ignoring that he's
even denied it by simply ignoring it
right her follow-up question is he says
so her question just to read the
transcript is so senator Warren's I do
want to be clear here senator Sanders I
want to be clear you're saying you never
told senator Warren that a woman could
not win the election Sanders that is
correct
Philip the reporter senator Warren what
did you think when senator Sanders told
you a woman could not win the election
okay this is okay there's a there's a
textbook sort of story that is very
often told about bad reporting bad
reporting goes something like this you
walk up to a senator and you say to the
senator so senator when did you stop
beating your wife that's a textbook case
of a bad question the reason it's a bad
question is because it is assuming a
prior that is not in evidence and it's
assuming that the senator was beating
his wife so when did you stop beating
your wife is a great way of saying you
used to beat your wife right well this
is so Senator Warren when did senator
Sanders tell you what did you think when
senator Sanders told you that a woman
could not win the election
he's explicitly denied on this stage she
ever says it and the CNN reporter
immediately turns and says to Warren so
he's a liar what do you think of him
India's sexist liar which is morons
entire case in Bernie Sanders should
completely rethink his perspective on
campaign finance reform his perspective
is that corporations spending money on
politics is extremely dangerous what
does he have to what do you have to say
about CNN dropping a billion-dollar
in-kind donation directly on Elizabeth
Warren in the middle of a debate now he
knows what Mitt Romney felt like in 2012
and Candy Crowley decided that she was
just going to join the Obama campaign in
the middle of a presidential debate
unbelievable and then Warren who's just
a terrible she's terrible
she's just terrible in every way she
says I disagreed bernie is my friend I'm
not here to try to fight with Bernie all
I'm gonna do is just tell this story
this tale out of school two weeks before
the Iowa caucuses when I've lost all
momentum in order to try and sink Bernie
Sanders I listen you're making me stick
up I can't say this enough they are
making me stick up for Bernie Sanders
just trying to be an honest human being
okay that's it Bernie is my friend I'm
not here to try to fight with Bernie all
I'm gonna say is that he's a vicious
sexist who says that a woman can't be
President of the United States
that's her take what a scurrilous gross
attack by Elizabeth Warren but that's
what she is
scurrilous disgusting in her politics
because she's dishonest truly dishonest
and you want to assume the best
intentions of people with whom you
disagree
I assume that Bernie Sanders genuinely
feels what he feels I am NOT going to
grove to grant Elizabeth Warren that
same credibility I do not think she
feels what she feels I do not think that
she stands by any of her position
I do not think that she's honest in any
real way I think that she's willing to
do anything in order to access power I
think Bernie at least to his credit he
says what he says he's the Popeye
he's the Popeye the sailorman of
politics he is what he is he's strong to
the finish when he eats his spinach but
Elizabeth Warren that lady blows with
the wind and not only that she is a
knife fighter my goodness I mean just
stabs him directly between the shoulder
blades and CNN acquiescing and all of us
not just acquiescing but participating
an accessory to the political murder of
Bernie Sanders in Siena that is some
that's some top-notch reporting some
real solid journalism in there CNN okay
and then this led to this very confused
exchange by the way Bernie Sanders is
not wrong in this exchange he's not it's
just that Elizabeth Warren was careful
and how she tailored this I love when
Elizabeth Warren said I'm the only
person on this stage who's beaten an
incumbent Republican any time in the
past 30 years okay let's get something
straight you beat Scott Brown in
Massachusetts Scott Brown is the
greatest electoral fluke in modern
political history he won because Ted
Kennedy plotzed okay Ted Kennedy plotzed
the seat had to be filled it was the
middle of the Obamacare debate and seven
people voted in Massachusetts and Scott
Brown was Senator of Massachusetts for
7.2 minutes but Elizabeth was like I
beat an incumbent in Massachusetts which
has had one Republican senator in the
last 900 years but she's but she's real
bipartisan fighter is Elizabeth Warren
so Bernie tries to come back from this
he comes back in the dumbest possible
way because again Bernie ain't that
bright and Bernie has he knows what he
is and he is what he is but what he is
is a rather dim bulb so here is senator
Warren going at it with Bernie Sanders
over who has defeated an incumbent
Republican the two most radical members
of the Democratic Party on that stage
trying to proclaim that they have
appealed to Republicans because one beat
a Republican in Vermont in 1990 and the
other beat a Democrat in Massachusetts
in 2010 I mean this is all just
ridiculous crap senator Sanders you can
are so just to set the record straight I
defeated an incumbent Republican running
for Congress when 1990
that's how I won beat a Republican
Congressmen number two I don't think
there's any debate of you thirty years
ago I beat an incumbent Republican its
congressman and I said I was the only
one who's beaten an incumbent Republican
in 30 years
well thirty years ago as 1919 as a
matter of fact but I don't know that
that's the major issue of the day I
think what the major issue of the day is
let's does anybody in their right mind
think that a woman cannot be elected
president I want to give you the final
of course I do think it's the right
question how do we beat Trump and here's
the thing since Donald Trump was elected
women candidates have outperformed men
candidates in competitive races and in
2018 we took back the house we took back
state houses because of women candidates
and women voters look don't deny that
the question is there back in the 1960s
people asked could a Catholic win back
in 2008 people asked if an
african-american could win in both times
the Democratic Party stepped up and said
yes got behind their candidate and we
changed America that's who we are
she's just awful she's just the worst
I love that I'm a woman and because
she's basically Cory Booker but a woman
Cory Booker just spent the last you know
two months going around going guys I'm
black black I comment Harris is not in
the race anymore I'm the only black guy
in a bridge like so Elizabeth Warren is
now I'm a woman don't you see I used to
say I was a Native American and that
wasn't true but actually a woman I
mentioned I can't define woman because I
think that men can be whipped but I'm
actually don't you know and me being
elected it would just be just like the
first black president if a woman was
elected Prime she's so tiresome she's so
unbelievably tiresome and so is CNN
senator Warren now and it gives you the
last word matter that's silly exchange
about who defeated an incumbent
Republican 30 years ago versus ten years
ago it's so dumb and it's so trite and
it's so tired Elizabeth Warren is
I work with a single Republican she
never has Bernie Sanders is not gonna
work with a single Republican she never
has and neither of them are gonna be
President so it's irrelevant anyway in
just a second we'll see more of CNN
piling on Bernie I mean really if you're
if you're a Bernie fan at this point you
got to be thinking when's the dudes
gonna run third party because the number
of people who are just out to get
burning is extraordinary like they're
people like me I'll come at Bernie from
the front right I'm going right at
Bernie's ideology I think the Bernie is
wrong on everything I think Bernie is
entirely off the grid when it comes to
intelligence political decency morality
like I'll come right at him
but inside the Democratic Party they are
willing to live off the back of Bernie
Sanders they're willing to hijack his
entire agenda and then ingest it ingest
it like a horror movie monster like some
stranger things just ingest the the
political flesh of Bernie Sanders and
use it to animate their monster body and
then just leave his desiccated corpse
behind I mean that is what the
Democratic Party does so if you're a
Bernie fan today you got to be thinking
yourself this is the guy who led your
entire movement he was an independent
for most of his career he comes inside
your party you tried to take his ideas
you tried to create this thing you know
this Elizabeth Warren Candis to see you
try to create that and then you try to
use that in order to promote Bernie
Sanders's ideas while sucking him dry
and then you want us to vote for you
guys like if you're a Bernie fan this is
a great way that the Democratic Party
and CNN have really alienated you pretty
impressive and we'll get to more of this
in just one second plus we'll get to the
latest on impeachment but if you are not
already a daily where I remember you are
indeed missing out right now using promo
code Schapiro you'll get 10% off any
plan you choose head over to daily where
DICOM slash subscribe think the plan
that is correct for you for as little as
10 bucks a month members get our
articles to add free access to all of
our live broadcast and show library the
full three hours of the Ben Shapiro
shows selected bonus content access to
the mailbag and more plus our new
all-access tear gets you into exclusive
live online Q&A discussions with me
Andrew Clavin Matt Walsh Michael Mills
Plus daily wire writers and special
guests and don't forget you'll also get
the greatest of all beverage vessels the
left is tears tumblr yes you get all of
that plus 10% off today when you use the
promo code Shapiro 10% off is a good
deal so stop depriving yourself come and
join the fun we're the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
Abbey Philip just kept going and going
and going after Bernie Sanders who's
really an impressive showing my Abby
Philip who's apparently running for the
Democratic nomination she's not just a
reporter for CNN
so last night on healthcare she went
after Bernie Sanders on the cost of his
health care plan now listen we've been
over this ground 1 million times Bernie
Sanders his health care plan is absurd
he would double the American budget like
forever minimum hey n your health care
would then be rationed by the government
because that is the only way that a
fully nationalized single-payer UK's
style health care system works there are
other ways to have mandates like they do
in Switzerland that works with private
industry in which you actually have some
competition for the taxpayer dollar
because the money isn't first funneled
through the government there's places
like Singapore that have mandates on
low-level insurance and then you can
purchase more above that and there are
ways to do this that are not
single-payer Bernie Sanders a single
player Medicare for all plan is
ridiculous on its face it is wildly
unpopular it gets rid of all your
insurance plans it does get rid of your
ability to see the doctor that you want
so all of these questions are fairly
directed at Bernie Sanders my only
question is this Elizabeth Warren Cribs
off Bernie Sanders his notes as Bernie
Sanders keep saying I won't the combo I
did I wrote it nobody voted for it but I
wrote the damn bill it's a bill and
battement I rolled it okay so Bernie at
least his Acrobat Elizabeth Warren sat
behind Bernie in class and cribbed off
his notes and then she tried to live off
those notes and then when it didn't work
for her she's like I was never for
Medicare for all
no I think that we have to do something
different and isn't it a better question
than asking Bernie for the one millionth
time why his plan is dumb wouldn't it be
better to ask Elizabeth Warren if his
plan is dumb as you now kind of see that
it is why did you embrace it in the
first place why have you shifted
positions more times then the characters
in the kamasutra like you shift your
position on Medicare for all routinely
and fluidly and ridiculously but instead
Abbey Philip goes after Bernie Sanders
which again it's a fair question it is
just unfair that Bernie Sanders is
singled out here's Abbey Philip senator
Sanders you've consistently refused to
say exactly how much your Medicare for
all plan is going to cost
don't voters deserve to see the price
tag before you send them a bill that
could cost tens of trillions of dollars
well what I will tell you is Medicare
for all which will guarantee
comprehensive health care to every man
woman and child will cost substantially
less than the status quo okay so that
that's always his answer and that this
is this weird notion that it costs less
than the status quo to tax people at
exorbitant rates cost less to whom to
whom I'm always amused when people
equate private spending to public
spending not the same thing not the same
thing at all in America we spend more
than any other country does on luxury
watches well if we just nationalized it
and everybody got the Casio like that's
not how markets work
so how markets work instead it was left
to the other Democrats to point out that
both Elizabeth Warren's plan and Bernie
Sanders's plan are completely
nonsensical here is Joe Biden again as
you'll notice Joe Biden was a spectator
for most of the night right Joe Biden
who was the front runner and who's
probably going to win the nomination was
just able to stand there or at least
they wheeled him up there in a dolly and
he sort of sat there lifelike but
somewhat animate and he said listen
you're your silly idea that you're gonna
be able to pay for this thing with like
a small income tax increase is just
nonsense I think we need to be candid
with voters I think we have to tell them
what we're gonna do and what it's going
to cost in a 4% tax on income over
twenty four thousand dollars doesn't
even come close to paying for between
thirty and some estimates as high as
forty trillion dollars over ten years
that's doubling the entire federal
budget per year of course that is a
hundred percent true of course that is
true and then listen to Warren some more
never get to ask the hard question
instead it's like Senator Warren that's
really what happened Abbey Philip just
turned to Senator Warren instead of
instead of saying so you proposed
Bernie's plan then you decided that
Bernie's plan was not workable and you
shifted away from it which means you're
a coward so what happened senator Warren
instead it turns into senator Warren and
senator Warren then proceeds to babble
cream of wheat for half a minute
my approach to this is we've got to get
as much help to as many people as
quickly as possible I've worked out a
plan where we can do that without
raising taxes on middle-class families
by one thin dime no nope nope nope nope
nope and it's left to Amy Klobuchar to
point out that Senator Warren is deeply
unprincipled and dishonest here is Amy
Klobuchar
who's been an afterthought in the race
but her critiques of the Medicare for
all plans are of course spot-on
by the way people do judge was not even
there last
night people to judge basically stood
there he said his usual shtick no one
cares it's been fun
catch you later Pete anyway Amy
Klobuchar she went after Warren but
nobody in the media will say no Warren
you acknowledged that medicare-for-all
that you couldn't get there right away
you got on the bill that said on page
eight which is why I didn't get on it
that you would kick a hundred forty nine
million Americans off their current
health insurance then a few months ago
you said no you're gonna wait a while to
get there and I think that was some
acknowledgment that maybe what we're
talking about is true yes correct but
where where so to CNN have any follow-up
questions for Senator Warren about that
no instead Abbey Philip goes after
Sanders Abbey Philip mean I don't know
if she was on Warren's payroll or what
the story was last night but it was
pretty impressive isn't impressive
showing here's Abby Phillip going after
Sanders on his spending programs again
now listen we know Bernie Sanders is a
socialist he just wants to nationalize
all the industries guys
he just wants outputting to be owned by
the masses he wants socialist ownership
of the means of production in tapioca
pudding is it all that difficult it's
not difficult at all but instead of AIB
Philip asking Elizabeth Warren so lady
you keep proposing all this crazy crap
spending and then you propose a wealth
tax it's unconstitutional to pay for it
that has no support among Congress
people and then you proclaim yourself
more moderate than Bernie so what's the
deal and said she goes after Sanders
again on the fact that he's a crazy old
kook who likes to spend a lot of money
like nothing has changed here here is
Abbey Philip going after Sanders again
senator Sanders your campaign proposals
would double federal spending over the
next decade an unprecedented level of
spending not seen since World War two
how would you keep your plans from
bankrupting the country our plans
wouldn't bankrupt the country in fact it
would much improve of the well-being of
working-class families and the middle
class yes this is again a be fill up
going after Sanders and Sanders giving
another dumb answer but these Democratic
debates and my goodness they have not
been good for the Democrats really not
good for the Democrats and Joe Biden the
front where the dude can't even string
together a sentence listen to Joe
Biden's answer on health care right here
he seems to forget exactly where he is
and seems to suffer some sort of some
sort of lapse in the middle of the
answer
I would argue that the way you control
drug prices is you limit to what they
can charge for those prices you don't
have to pay the price limit what they
can charge if in fact they charge more
than we set the price for they can they
can in fact we can people can import
from abroad assuming that it is safe we
in fact it's only yellow ok what what's
going on now no one knows ok well there
was more to the debate but that was
basically the story the night it was
Warren and Sanderson and Tom Steyer
who's just kind of hanging out there was
likewise Tom Styer here and the answer
is because he spent a lot of money on
that stage a lot of money to be on that
stage Tom Styer is closing is worthy of
note simply because this person has
somehow been able to buy his way to 15%
support in the early states according to
the latest polling here is Tom Steyer
saying some weird stuff about how Sports
is played which is odd
I played team sports my entire life the
bond between teammates is deep and
emotional and full of love and as far as
I'm concerned the American people are my
teammates and if there's one thing I
will not permit it is someone to run
down the field and kick my teammate in
the face that was a wild shift some
buddies do you even know what sport
we're going I'm pretty sure that
somebody would throw the penalty but my
favorite part of that is that he's on
the same stage as Elizabeth Warren who
just put a boot in Bernie Sanders his
face his teammate and he's sitting there
like I'm not getting involved he's
literally the third person as Elizabeth
Warren comes over and gets in a fight
with Bernie Sanders late yeah five
seconds after he says I will not permit
anyone to take a boot and put it in my
teammates face he's standing there going
what am I supposed to do as Bernie is
approached by Warren who refuses to
shake his hand because again she's not a
nice person it this tape I'm never gonna
get over it we're going to have to we're
going to have to get a lip reader in
here because there's no question you
could probably figure out what they are
saying but stires like so remember that
time when I said I was gonna be brave
and defend my allies yeah I'm just gonna
like walk over here I'm just gonna see
ya later a little bit Trevor Noah
had this exactly right know has actually
been quite good on the democratic
debates he said this is like an old
couple arguing at the diner no no but
it's it's just irritating and flush that
was the most unnecessary nitpicky
argument you will ever see in a
presidential debate you know what it
felt like it felt like we were watching
an old couples fight in a diner that's
what it looked like you know I thought
you said you were getting an appetizer
yeah I am I'm getting soup that is an
appetizer
no soup is this I know if it comes
before the meal it's an appetizer
correct and and then CNN's Van Jones
sums it up well he said listen there is
nothing on that stage that can take out
Trump nothing on that stage can take out
Trump which is a hundred percent true
whoo-hoo iMessage is gonna take out
Trump Elizabeth Warren who's most
calculated and knowing pal I mean she is
so much more annoying than Hillary
Clinton I used to think not but she has
gotten to be so irritating and so
self-righteous and so terrible she's
less corrupt than Hillary Clinton
because she hasn't had as long a history
in politics but she is just the
self-righteousness with which she treats
everybody else when she herself is the
most cynical politician on the stage is
truly going and then you have Bernie who
is just a 19 a 1918 wobbly he's just
that he's like an actual international
socialist of America and then you have
Joe Biden who's not even he sent and
he's a starfish at this point he's got
the sentient qualities of a of a basic
form of biological life Van Jones on
Sanna is like yeah I'm not feeling great
today guys not great to see those two
have that level of vitriol was very
dispiriting and i want to say that
tonight for me was dispiriting the
democrats to have to do better what we
saw tonight there was nothing i saw
tonight that would be able to take
Donald Trump out and I want to see a
Democrat in the White House as soon as
possible there was nothing tonight that
if you're looking at this thing you say
did any of these people are prepared for
what Donald Trump is gonna do to us and
to see further division tonight is very
dispiriting well yeah I mean it should
be dispiriting if you're a Democrat and
if you're a Bernie if you're a Bernie
fan you've got to be fighting that and
you got to be thinking yourself this
Democratic Party the way they've treated
this guy is truly egregious because it
is just from any objective level the way
that Ivan Krank party has treated
Sanders is truly egregious and yes I'm
being a little bit cynical because I
would love to see the Bernie fans stay
home from the polls and not vote for
Elizabeth Warren or Joe Biden because
they're ticked off sure I'd love to see
that I'm not gonna pretend I have a dog
in this fight but just try
to take myself out of it if I were
Bernie fan today which I am not even as
a non Bernie fan just trying to be
honest that was that was truly awful it
was truly awful in every way and
honestly I wouldn't be surprised to see
Bernie get a little bump
I wouldn't yeah just just because he's
not Elizabeth Warren and she is awful in
every way and so CNN CNN deserves all
the flack they're taking today alrighty
well quick thing that I like and then we
will and then we'll give you the quick
impeachment update so the quick thing
that I like is I mentioned early on it
is my birthday that is a good time to
express my appreciation to all of you
thank you for bringing us through
another year thank you to the fans thank
you to people who listened to the show
and honestly I'm more grateful you
listen to message of the show than you
listen to the show itself thanks to all
of our members who helped us bring the
show to Everett thanks to our fantastic
staff over here I know there's an Oscar
speech now and I shouldn't be giving an
Oscar speech because I'm not actually a
transgender half Native American half
half black woman but it doesn't matter
I'm gonna thank everybody on staff who
when I'm not ripping on them in zipper
corner ads actually does a quite fine
job and thanks to all by the business
partners and every else thanks to my
family obviously best birthday present
so far I received actually from the
Jewish publisher art scroll they sent me
an iPad loaded up with all of their
material you should go check out art
school they're great they're two really
big Jewish publishers core and there are
scroll both of them are fantastic so
that is a shout out to Mizzou crew but
in any case we run the media and the
weather guys but thanks so much - I've
gotten a lot of emails wishing me happy
birthday I really am honored by that and
I'm grateful for your prayers and your
birthday wishes it really means a lot to
me okay now quick impeachment update so
the Democrats have now sent their
impeachment managers over to the Senate
and those managers are going to be Adam
Schiff and Jerry Nadler which is not a
surprise shift shares the Intelligence
Committee Nadler chairs the Judiciary
Committee that is Pelosi steering
directly into conflicts because she
figures that shift will be ask tough
questions by Republicans that shift will
be dragged through the mud and that
controversy is not bad for her because
frankly this thing is generating no heat
at all any heat that is generated she
hopes will lead to headlines over
impeachment since most people have
already tuned out at this point that is
why she is sending over chef and and
Jerry Nadler as well
as far as the witnesses is clear that
witnesses will be called there are not
the votes to just dismiss this thing out
of hand
there are too many Republican senators
who already said they want when it says
frankly I won't witness
I have no fear of witnesses saying
whatever it is they're going to say more
transparency is good whether we're
talking Democrats or whether we are
talking Republicans so that is where
things stand in terms of impeachment the
vote is taking place today to send over
the impeachment charges to the Senate
the trial is supposed to start next
Tuesday so we are going to be treated to
the spectacle in all likelihood of the
President of the United States giving a
State of the Union address to a joint
session of Congress well under the
threat of impeachment which should be
pretty great TV I don't really like to
stay to the Union address I think it's a
man article stupid institution but I
will be watching that won't you do all
right well that's all we have for today
at least for now later today on my
birthday I will shop for two additional
hours of content this is why I should go
subscribe over at daily we're calm so
check us out later for more content and
more updates otherwise we'll see you
here tomorrow i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Rebecca Dodd poets directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey supervising
producers Mathis Glover and Robert
Stirling technical producer Austin
Stephens associate producer Colton Haas
assistant director pavel white house key
edited by adam sai events audio is mixed
by Mike Romina hair and makeup is by
Jess wah alvera production assistant
Nick Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a
daily wire production copyright day Lee
Weyer 2020 with just 20 days to go
before the Iowa caucuses the Democrats
faced off last night in Des Moines Iowa
and everybody lost that's right nobody
won not Biden up burning out Warren not
feet not the voters certainly not the
viewers every candidate did terribly we
will examine why and how that train
wreck happened and what it means for
20/20 check it out on the Michael Noel's
show
[Music]